foreign
Camp I've seen all the movies man I see
how Michael B gets down I love a
challenge so I'm always up for one
don't get me ready for the ring I'm very
excited to be a part of this amazing
opportunity I'm about to go suit up
right now with my mouth Pizza
on me so I had to go run up a check
you're gonna be adversity you're gonna
meet hurdles struggles push yourself but
can you get my cup and go again exactly
like Creed
pick up yourself everyone I'm Mark Rhino
Smith personal trainer to the stars and
we're here today to do Creed Camp it's
going to be beneficial impactful and
freaking hard work are you ready for
this
tell Michael B come see me follow me guy
you ready
[Music]
Creed Three there's extreme Buzz Michael
B Jordan and Jonathan ages are training
they both put in was off the chart what
I'm most excited about when it comes to
Creed 3 just the fact that creep is
coming back out Michael B Jordan
Jonathan Majors man they're amazing
actors seeing Michael B Jordan fight
adversity something that that I live
with that I look forward to
[Music]
did I think that the Creed Camp was
going to be intense absolutely which is
why I didn't work out this morning I
wanted to make sure I had all my energy
all right here we go so look inverted
Rose for your back we try and break the
earth
I represent all the short dudes under
five eight and a half and that's the the
true triumphant of creed heart ready DJ
I need to know everything who in the
weather know where I need everything
trust me I hear what you're saying but I
like it's new what you're telling me
man if I had a nickname coming into the
Creed movie it had to be something
dangerous Houdini because now you see me
now you don't
gotta keep quiet call me smoke I'm
elusive the freak I'm a freak of nature
[Music]
what a break we're going to the Circuit
my Creed 3 prediction in BJ I know he's
gonna win it's a little bit biased but
Jonathan Majors is incredible he trains
like a madman I definitely want to see
Michael B Jordan come out on top foreign
boxers can really feel that their craft
has been respected to the utmost highest
level with Michael B Jordan and Jonathan
Majors just to see Michael B Jordan and
Jonathan majors in the ring together
that's going to be super iconic and it's
good to see somebody actually know what
they're doing in the ring I think the
storyline is perfect because it happens
in real life you know friends friends
turn into enemies yo so this is the
finale this is the home run from the
South Side
Victorious ain't just me it's more of us
and we out here we out here it was an
amazing workout I wanted to get back
into boxing and this just inspired me to
actually get into it so I can get sharp
I knew we were gonna break a sweat I
knew we were going to turn the heat up
and we did just that this prepared me
for the fight of my life made me feel
like I should be casted in Korea for I
actually impressed my own self I didn't
know I could go this
I feel like I could be a Cree Champion
for sure I thought it was amazing it put
on the effort the hard work and even
when they wanted to give up they dusted
their shoulders off and they came again
a shout out to the Creed Camp they came
they done it they conquered Creed Three
don't miss it next level
foreign